otro trágico récord parada de
degradación de la amazonía brasileña en
el primer semestre de 2022 la
deforestación arrasó con tres mil 988
kilómetros cuadrados de selva un 10 6%
más que el mismo período del año
anterior según los datos del propio
gobierno de brasil
esto es muy malo el primer semestre en
el amazonas es cuando tenemos la
temporada de lluvias por lo que no
deberíamos estar viendo estos números
tan altos por lo que tenemos una
combinación de un clima más seca con una
motivación para el fútbol
de first la vegetación de la selva
tropical más grande del mundo queda
reducida a tierra y madera para su venta
grandes extensiones que serán empleadas
principalmente para la ganadería y los
macro cultivos desde la llegada del
ultraderechista jair bolsonaro al poder
las cifras de deforestación se han
incrementado ante la falta de controles
gubernamentales y de políticas públicas
para frenar las actividades ilícitas que
conlleva la deforestación y su
suministro
es difícil ser optimista para los
próximos meses el amazon sabemos incluso
por estudios académicos que en año
electoral tenemos un aumento de la
deforestación por lo que se ha
deforestado en este primer semestre es
muy posible que también haya muchos
incendios durante el verano amazónico la
estación seca
si bien esta problemática preocupa más
fuera que dentro de brasil con una larga
tradición de deforestación potenciada
desde las mismas instituciones en los
años 80 y una carencia de conciencia
medioambiental los ambientalistas
confían que sea un tema de campaña de
cara a los comicios de octubre